It's possible that you guys have been
following this political and economic
news from the Ukraine,
so it says here that this is off CBC in
a clear warning to Ukraine.
Putin on Wednesday ordered massive
military exercises involving most of the
military units in western Russia
on Thursday as part of the exercises.
Fighter jets were put on combat alert
and we're patrolling the border.
Russia's defense ministry said in the
statement it didn't specify the areas
where patrol missions were being
conducted.
The military also announced measures to
tightened security at the headquarters
of Russia's Black Sea Fleet on the
Crimean Peninsula and south eastern
Ukraine.
There's a rumor that I believe,
I believe it was [inaudible] gave the
Crimea to the Ukraine when he was drunk.
The military maneuvers prompted a sharp
rebuke from us,
secretary of state,
John Kerry,
who warned Russia that any military
intervention in Ukraine would be a grave
mistake.
So
why did I tell you that?
Well,
it's,
it's for the same reason that I've been
conducting these last few lectures on
phenomenal logical and existential ideas
in psychotherapy and I think I mentioned
to you that these ideas are often not
covered anymore in personality classes,
but I think that's a big mistake because
I think that these theories have more to
tell us about
what happened in the 20th century than
any other theories that I've ever come
across.
And that's very important because
that,
that terrible mass movements of the 20th
century occurred because of the nature
of people's personality and it's a
mistake to concentrate on.
It's a mistake not to concentrate on
factors that play that massive a role in
determining the destiny of the entire
world.
And you know it.
It may seem to you that the Soviet Union
is a long ways away since it collapsed
in 1989,
but there's no evidence that we're done
with it yet.
I mean,
potent was a kgb officer and the KGB was
the Soviet secret service and the Soviet
secret service was one catastrophic Lee
awful organization
and the tension that's occurring in the
Ukraine right now that looks like it
might explode into civil war and
hopefully not is still a consequence of
the remnants of the pathologies that
dominated the Soviet Union for for most
of the 20th century.
It isn't clear to me that we've really
learned what we had to learn from what
happened in Nazi Germany say and in
Mao's China,
which is obviously still run by the
communist party or in the Soviet Union.
Even though there's been a reprieve for
the last 35 years or so.
Meet you in particular,
predicted what was going to happen in
the 20th century.
I'm going to read you something that he
wrote.
I'm going to try to tell you today why
the events in the 20th century happened.
So the mass genocidal movements in
particular,
which were probably the defining
characteristic of the 20th century and
then also what that has to do with
individual psychology.
My first degree was in political science
and I was interested in political
science because I was interested
fundamentally and the reason that human
societies went to war and when I was
studying political science,
which is quite a long time ago,
the fundamental theory that underlie
political scientists,
explanations for conflict or economic
people fight over resources and that
never seemed reasonable to me because
first of all,
obviously many wars are fought for other
reasons than resources.
Um,
to Central American countries.
I think it was Guatemala and Honduras,
if I remember correctly,
went to war over a soccer game.
So the outcome of the disputed,
the disputed outcome of a soccer game.
And even if you do think that the reason
that people,
groups of people engage in conflict are
for economic reasons.
That doesn't exactly explain much
because that doesn't explain whether
they are fighting for because of
absolute differences in wealth or
because of relative discrepancies and
wealth and those.
Those are very,
very different causal elements.
And then even if people do fight for
economic reasons,
which means they're fighting for things
that they value,
it isn't exactly clear why people value
what they value because different
societies value different things.
So economics in the final analysis ends
up being a shallow explanation and I
pursued economic and political and
sociological explanations for social
conflict for a long time.
But eventually they became untenable to
me.
And that's partly why I went and studied
clinical psychology because it struck me
that the right level of analysis for
understanding mass movements like the
Nazi movement or the or the the
ideological possession that
characterized the Stalinist Soviet
communists or or or Pol Pot's,
Cambodian communists or any of the
dictators that you can talk about who
are on the far left or the far right
during the 20th century.
To me,
those were failings of individual
personality and the most astute writers
that I've ever read who described what
they assume to be the causes of these
terrible conflicts made the same point.
Which is why I'm having you read Viktor
Frankl and Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn
associates and is not generally regarded
as a personality psychologist.
But he,
of all the people I've ever read,
he's the one who lays out the connection
between the existential failure of the
individual and the mass catastrophes of
society.
And to me that's too important to link
to overlook.
And it.
It also strikes me that it's the primary
lesson of the 20th century mean.
One lesson for example,
is beware of videology.
So the reason I'm going to walk you
through Nea Chin,
a bit of Kierkegaard today is because
these people in the late 19th century
with their antennas up knew that the
collapse,
one way of looking at is the collapse of
traditional Western values.
That's one way of looking at what setup
the preconditions for the people's
humanity.
Susceptibility to dog is in the 20th
centuries,
in the 20th century.
The other way of looking at it in some
senses that as the world came together
in the 19th century and ideas were
passed around from culture to culture
more rapidly than they had ever been
passed around.
Every culture suffered.
D culturation in some sense because if I
believe something and you believe
something and there's a long history
behind both of our beliefs,
when we come into contact with will
either fight and I'll try to destroy you
or or if I don't,
if I take you seriously and you take me
seriously,
then that's going to leave us both
wondering exactly what's what's rock
solid underneath us.
That's what needs to comments on on in
this particular quilt
of what is Great.
One either must be silent or speak with
greatness,
with greatness.
That means cynically in with innocence.
What I relate is the history of the next
two centuries.
I described what is coming,
what can no longer come differently?
The advent of nihilism.
Nihilism is the belief that nothing
or the belief that things have no
meaning.
Our whole European culture is moving for
some time now with a tortured tension
that is growing from decade to decade as
towards a catastrophe
restlessly violently and headlong like a
river that wants to reach the end that
no longer reflects it,
is afraid to reflect.
He that speaks here has conversely done
nothing so far but to reflect as a
fellow philosopher and solitary by
instinct who has found his advantage in
standing,
aside outside,
why has the event advent of nihilism
become necessary
because the values we have had hitherto
thus draw their final consequence
because nihilism represents the ultimate
logical conclusion of our great values
and ideals.
Because we must experience nihilism
before we can find out what value those
values really
we require at some time.
New Values.
Nihilism stands at the door.
Whence comes this uncanny first of all,
guests
point of departure.
It's an error to consider social
distress or physiological degeneration
or corruption of all things as the cause
of nihilism.
Ours is the most honest and
compassionate age,
so Nisha dispenses right away with
sociological explanations for people's
lack of belief in meaning in life.
You know what?
A lot of what you're taught in
universities is sociological in its
causal thinking that the causal path is
often that's the social conditions that
people find themselves in that
determined their response to the world,
but niches stands violently against that
perspective.
And this is 150 years ago,
even before in some sense it was
thoroughly well developed and the reason
he stands against it is because he
points out that
wherever you're positioned in society,
your position can be made subject to any
number of individual interpretations.
It's meaning like the meaning of being
poor,
say,
or the meaning of being comparatively
poor isn't a meaning that's etched in
stone and so it.
It has to be interpreted psychologically
before it can become a causal factor,
and if it can be interpreted
psychologically,
then it's not a fact like the existence
of a mountain is a fact.
It's still an interpretation.
He says,
distress itself,
whether psychic,
psychological,
physical,
or intellectual also need not produce
nihilism.
So he also reject suffering itself as a
cause of nihilism.
Need not at all produced nihilism.
That is the radical rejection of value,
meaning and desirability.
Such distress always permits a variety
of interpretations.
Rather it is in one particular
interpretation.
The Christian moral nihilism is rooted
the end of Christianity at the hands of
its own morality which cannot be
replaced,
which turns against the Christian God.
The sense of truthfulness,
highly developed by Christianity is
nauseated by the falseness and
mendacious snus of all Christian
interpretations of the world and of
history to rebound from God is the truth
to the fanatical faith,
all his false and active
Buddhism.
So it's a strange interpretation because
Nietzsche,
although he was violently anti Christian
in his,
in his what in his self presentation to
the public was more like a,
in my opinion,
was more like a beneficial critic of,
of the,
of the western Christian tradition and
because the first thing he realized was
that the domination of the West by
essentially by the Catholic church for
something like 1900 years was necessary
in order for,
for the European mind to become trained
and focused.
So his point was that you,
unless you learn to place an
interpretive scheme on the world and
interpret that world in a coherent
manner through that scheme,
you don't have a trained mind.
And,
and,
and for Nietzsche in some sense,
it didn't really matter what the
interpretive scheme was.
It was just that at some point you had
to discipline yourself.
And this would be something like a post
adolescent process you had to discipline
yourself by developing an adherence to
some sort of coherent deep,
coherent view and the consequence of
that,
at least in principle,
could be that you would be this.
You could come to be the sort of person
that would,
that would be respectful of the truth
and also someone who was who regarded
truth as a,
as a moral virtue,
as a higher order,
more virtual,
but then he just point was that
Christianity developed that sense in
Europe to such a degree that the spirit
of truth seeking went after the axioms
of Christianity and demolished them.
That was his view of what happened
during the enlightenment as a
consequence of the interaction between
science and religion.
So
Nietzsche's view was that the modern
mind will say,
because we're speaking 150 years later,
the modern mind had been trained
rigorously to interpret things through a
coherent structure.
And then once that training had
occurred,
then it could use any number of coherent
structures.
And then it could also use it's ability
to form a relationship with the truth.
To criticize the very thing that gave
rise to that mind and that and that
Nietzsche's diagnosis of the 20th
century individual,
a pursuit of truth itself had undermined
the structure that gave birth to the
pursuit of truth and that left people
wide open and left them wide open.
On the one hand to nihilism and nihilism
is the belief that nothing has meaning.
Nothing has any final meeting and the
best way of expressing nihilism is what
the hell difference is it going to make
in a,
in a thousand years what we do today or
in 100 years for that matter,
and it's a real.
It's a rational reduction of,
of all of the experiences of life to,
to,
to rational insignificance.
Nothing has any final meaning.
And so the question of course that
emerges from that is,
well,
why do anything on a deeper question
that emerges for that?
From that is,
well,
why bear suffering?
And but that's not the only problem from
an existential point of view because the
existentialists and niches,
well also believed that nihilism was
actually unbearable because people
suffer.
They have to have a framework of meaning
in which to place the suffering because
otherwise it undermines their ability to
live and then people can't move forward
in that condition,
and so another one of Nietzsche's
prognostications was that nihilism would
produce its counterpart which was
totalitarianism and people would leap
from their immersion,
say in in,
in,
in evolutionarily emergent systems of
faith and jump head long into rational
utopian constructions of reality because
you,
because people can't do without an
interpretive framework,
so it wasn't as if the consequence of
moving beyond religion was going to be a
step into enlightenment,
which is what materialist rationalist
all's was presumed.
They presume if you could just shed the
superstitious clap trap that's
associated with your religious heritage,
you'd instantly be enlightened,
but niches point was that is not what's
likely to happen.
What's likely to happen.
There's two things.
People will either give up on life
completely and become cynical
prematurely.
Cynical,
which is certainly a disease of of young
people.
Maybe it's always been a disease of
young people,
but it's certainly been a disease of
young people since say the end of World
War Two.
So they become nihilistic and not
believe that anything has any meaning,
and that undermines their ability to
strive or they'd fall prey to some sort
of rigid ideology and niche.
He also understood that if people fell
prey to a religion to originate theology
or several rigid ideologies,
that the only plausible outcome of that
would be like ics,
exceptionally intense warfare.
And of course that's exactly what
happened in the 20th century.
Now he also says this can't be reversed.
Skepticism regarding morality is what is
decisive.
The end of the moral interpretation of
the world,
which no longer has any sanction after
just tried to escape into some beyond
leads to nihilism,
all lacks meaning.
Then he says the untenable.
We have one interpretation of the world
upon which a tremendous amount of energy
has been lavished,
awakens the suspicion that all
interpretations of the world are false.
So it's a brilliant observation because
he.
His point is,
I've seen this in,
in fundamentalist Christians,
for example,
who who I've taught in the past because
I have a very biological view of things
and these people.
I met more of them when I was in the
United States.
They were more intelligent than
than they were wise,
meaning the constraints within which
their intellect was forced to operate,
which would be the Christian
fundamentalists.
Constraints were not sophisticated
enough to encapsulate their intellect.
They were too smart for their own
theories,
so they come to university and and and
be exposed to ideas that were outside
the scope,
say of Christian fundamentalism would
just blow their fundamentalist
presuppositions into bits and so then of
course they fall into nothing but Nina
says it's even worse than that.
It's not only that you fall into
nothing,
it's that once one of your systems of
belief has been destroyed,
you also learn that systems of beliefs
themselves are unreliable and so you
can't just move easily from one to
another because it's like,
well,
you're in a boat and it sunk,
and now you know that if you jump to the
next boat,
that boat could also sake.
So it's.
It's not only that your boat has sunk,
it's now you know that all boats can
sync,
and so that's part of the position of
the modern person as far as nature is
concerned,
is that every one of us knows,
at least in principle,
that all the boats that we wanted jump
into could potentially sink and so Nicha
saw nihilism as the inevitable
consequence.
The inevitable rational consequence of
that realization.
Now,
I told you guys before,
Nisha was a very,
very influential person,
influential,
influenced heidegger,
and heidegger influenced pinks,
Wanger and boss,
but nature also influenced young as much
as Freud did and young spent his whole
career trying to solve the question that
needs to post.
One of the questions was
because we must experience nihilism
before we can find out what value these
values really have.
So
the collapse of a belief system makes
all the values within it.
No longer tenable that that's the
meaning of niches statement,
that God is dead.
He said,
if you take the central axiom out of a
system of belief,
you can't hold on to all the things that
were derived from that axiom.
So here an example is this,
so for example,
in,
in modern Western law there's a
presupposition and the presupposition is
that in some weird sense everyone is
equal before the law and that's
predicated on the idea that not even
applies to someone who's a murderer.
You're a murderer and you and it's
known.
You have to be treated with respect,
you know,
you have to be treated with respect by
the legal system.
And that's a very,
very strange.
It's a miracle that,
that something like that ever emerged
because it's so unlikely.
So then you might ask,
well,
what is the idea that everyone has worth
before the law grounded in,
where does that idea come from?
It comes from the idea of natural rights
that we have natural rights.
And then you might ask,
well where did the idea of natural
rights come from?
Well then you're,
then you're starting to move beyond the
realm of rational philosophy because
natural rights,
the idea of natural rights has been
something that has been an idea that's
been emerging for thousands and
thousands of years.
You know it's grounded in Christianity
at least two in the in the map.
It's grounded in Christianity to the
degree that one of the things that
distinguishes Christianity is the idea
that there's a universal faith and that
everyone,
whether they're in that faith or not,
has intrinsic value and so natural
rights are grounded in the idea of the
intrinsic value of the soul and then
that's grounded in the idea that
consciousness itself participates in
creation and say that's an idea that's
embedded in genesis and also in most
creation stories.
So when you get rid of the religious
underpinnings,
which which,
which ground the entire system in a kind
of dreamlike mythology.
When you get rid of that,
there's no reason that what's leftover
rationally can survive and,
and,
and you can see that if you look at what
happened in the 20th century because
there were at least two major challenges
to the,
to the civilizations that evolved and
they weren't only Christian or Jewish
civilization.
The same thing happened in China.
There,
there was a replacement of these evolve
moral systems that emerged over a
tremendous amount of time that no one
rationally created once people started
to criticize them and to destroy the
axioms on which they were built and move
them aside.
Then there was a gaping hole left and
the hole was filled well.
It was filled most particularly either
by Nazi-ism,
which spread like mad throughout central
Europe or by communism,
which still possesses China,
so it'll even though China came from,
from a,
from a historical culture that was
substantially different from say that of
Western Europe once,
once,
once rationality emerged to the point
where it can be used as a critical force
which happened in Europe that spread
like mad and it undermined the societies
of China.
Just like it undermined the societies of
the West.
I mean Russia.
You can read.
You can read this if you read Tolstoy,
for example,
tolstoy's confessions.
Russia was really the last country that
underwent the transformations that were
associated with the enlightenment.
So when tolstoy was a young person in
the late 19th century,
he lived.
He said he could literally remember when
the announcement spread through his
school that God was dead.
Now you're western Europeans had been
working on that idea for a couple of
hundred years,
you know,
with the dawn of the dawn of scientific
thinking,
but the Russians were very backwards in
some sense,
and they never,
they never.
They were never affected by the conflict
between rationality and religion until
it happened all at once and it happened
all at once at the end of the 19th
century,
and the consequence of that,
it's complicated,
but the consequence of that was that the
monarchy exploded and then the
consequence of that was that the
Russians were left with nothing and the
consequences of that was the Bolshevik
revolution,
and then that was what started the
entire Soviet nightmare.
You see very frequently that when a
society loses its grounding,
say it's historical truths,
that it turns to something as an
alternative.
You see,
the same thing happened in Quebec
because Quebec didn't undergo the modern
transformation until the late 19
fifties.
It was probably the last European
society to go through the enlightenment
revolution because the Catholic Church
was an incredibly dominant force in,
in,
in Catholic Quebec,
until the late 19 fifties in the average
family size during that time,
must've been in the neighborhood of 10
children and then all of a sudden in the
late 19 fifties,
the Quebec has just lost their
catholicism.
It was just gone and now,
for example,
the Quebecois have the lowest marriage
rate in the in the western world and one
of the lowest reproduction rates as
well.
And there was a Gallup poll that was
conducted.
I heard about this,
about must be 10 years ago.
Now.
I don't know if this information has
ever been made public,
but there was a Gallup poll that
indicated that if you are a Catholic who
had lost your faith,
so you left the church,
you were 10 times more likely to be a
separate list.
So you can see.
The consequence of it is,
is that if one belief system disappears,
well,
nihilism is one possibility,
but another possibility is that you just
adopt the next thing that's close.
That gives you structure and and
nationalism,
of course,
it's one of those things,
so nature does diagnose the disease
fundamentally,
and then the psychoanalysts like young
in particular,
they were trying to see neat.
You believe that if God died because God
died,
people were going to have to take on the
responsibility that was once gods,
so to speak,
as a personal problem,
so me and thus spake Zarathustra.
Nietzsche said,
God is dead.
We have killed him and we'll never find
enough water to wash away the blood.
But he also said in order for people to
withstand that catastrophe,
they would have to become gods
themselves essentially.
And while you can see how that might go
wrong if you think about people like
Stalin and Hitler,
but,
but the psychoanalysts also like
psychoanalysts especially you.
And then heidegger for,
for his part,
took that idea seriously and they young
young said,
was trying to figure out,
well,
if we lose our historically conditioned
values,
we no longer believe in them.
And if nihilism is the outcome on one
hand and totalitarianism is,
that would come.
On the other hand,
what's left and the union idea was while
the revelation of the self is that the
individual could not as a rational mind,
but the individual as a totality.
It's something that Rogers also believed
the individuals that totality would be
capable of bringing forth genuine values
as a consequence of self exploration and
honesty,
something like that,
and that's associated with the
existential idea of individual
responsibility.
So the one of the upshots of,
of the union theory is that to the
degree you don't bear the responsibility
for your own actions to the degree that
you avoid responsibility or shrunk them
off onto say,
totalitarian or ideological system.
So by when you avoid responsibility for
your own thoughts,
because if you're the follower of an
ideological system,
you have avoided the responsibility of
thinking for yourself and the
consequence of that was continual
catastrophe.
As those pathological rational systems
unfolded themselves,
Solzhenitsyn
wrote the Gulag archipelago in,
published it in early 19 seventies,
and
there were two things that made that
book very striking.
One was the stories that he told were so
unbelievably powerful that you couldn't
read them and not believe it was true,
and that was even the case if you were a
devoted Marxist and at that time in the
universities and in many ways it hasn't
changed that much.
The universities in the west were
dominated by Marxists and and to some
degree that was ethically inexcusable
because people had known since the 19
fifties,
especially since George Orwell wrote,
people had known since the 19 fifties
that this telling the state was
murderous beyond belief.
So Stalin for example,
killed 6 million Ukrainians in the 19
thirties.
He starved them to death.
He took because all of the farmers have
been collectivized at that point and
what that meant was all the good farmers
had been killed and all the resentful
farmers had been given the land and then
they collectivized farms and then sell
into all the food to feed the cities or
to or to start with the Ukrainians.
Depending on how you look at it and the
edicts were so harsh that if you are
Ukrainian and you had a family and they
were starving and you went into a field
after it had been harvested and you
picked out individual grains from the
dirt to gather in a bowl to feed your
family.
If you got caught,
then they would shoot you.
Solzhenitsyn observed this and he.
He was very interested in how this
system developed and his conclusion
after decades of thinking was that the
reason the Russian system was able to
maintain itself fundamentally was
because individuals were willing to give
up the responsibility of their own
relationship to the truth,
to the state and constantly lie to
themselves about everything.
And that if the.
If the individuals that compose the
state had refused to accept things that
they knew full well to be untrue,
that the state wouldn't have been able
to survive.
And you know,
social units.
It's case is very strong because in some
sense he was the first person who told
the truth about the Gulag archipelago,
which was this chain of prison camps
that the Soviets had erected on.
Which their economy was essentially
based.
He was the first person who really told
the truth about that and he hit the
foundations of Marx's theory so hard
that well,
partly it collapsed and partly it went
underground into movements like
postmodernism.
So his,
his proposition,
it's a dusty proposition actually.
That one person who stopped lying could,
could overturn a tyranny.
It's a hard thing to believe,
but there's been multiple examples of
that sort of thing.
In the 20th century it happened with
Gandhi happen with Vaclav Havel and
Czechoslovakia happen with Nelson
Mandela and Hatton was soldier nets and
you know,
so those are pretty powerful examples
of,
of the power of a single individual who
refuses to accept the convention.
The convention will lie.
Notice the Esky was writing about the
same time as Nietzsche.
And Dostoevsky is a very interesting
person.
He was an Orthodox Christian,
although he's a very intelligent man and
Dostoevsky.
Nietzsche are twins in some sense.
So what niche you wrote in philosophy,
Dostoevsky wrote in literature and
dusty,
dusty as keys primary
statements was that if there is no god,
everything is permitted.
So it's to take on niches,
discussion of nihilism,
it's like,
well,
if there's no ultimate value of any
sort,
then why can't you do exactly what you
want?
And that's a theme he explores to great
purpose in crime and punishment.
Neat Dostoyevsky's conclusion was that
the reason you can't do anything you
want is because you actually come
equipped with an inherent set of values
that are real and that if you violate
them to to greater degree,
you'll destroy your own structure as
well as damaging to society that's
around you.
So Dostoevsky was a big believer in some
sense like the unions and the Rogerian,
that there are the locus of values
within a human being and,
and,
and then it's an actual thing.
You can't disregard it without damage.
Dostoevsky was also a very powerful
critic of reason,
and the reason for that was
it was rezoned in some sense that
brought down the house of cards,
so to speak,
that constituted classical face.
But the consequence of that rational
destruction of values was the emergence
of nihilism or totalitarianism.
And the consequences of those two things
is either the inability to live or the
emergent emergence of the murderer
estate.
So Dostoevsky looked at that and
thought,
okay,
well perhaps our belief that reason
itself is the proper guide to reality is
wrong.
And so this is one of the things he
wrote in notes from underground when he
was exploring this idea notes from
underground.
By the way,
it's very short book and it's very much
worth reading.
It's a dusty Esky wrote five books that
are in calculus really great.
And what happened to Dostoevsky,
I don't remember if I told you this or
not,
but he was a student radical and he was.
He was arrested by the as men because of
a riot tour or a protest that him and
his compatriots had come up with.
He was sort of a bit player in it,
but they put them in prison when he was
a young man.
And then he was in prison for quite a
while.
And then one day they took him out into
the courtyard and they shot him at dawn.
You know,
they had the soldiers lining up and put
them by a post and shot them,
but they used blanks,
but he didn't know that and it scared
him so bad he had an epileptic seizure
and then he had epileptic seizures for
the rest of his life and the kind of
epileptic seizures he had were
associated with mystical experience,
so Dostoevsky before he got a seizure,
would have the sense that he was
experiencing the world in a more and
more meaningful way until he was on the
very dawn of sort of nip omniscient
knowledge and then he'd have a seizure,
but it wasn't until he was shot with
blanks and then putting this terrible
prison for a long period of time and had
epilepsy that he became a great
novelist.
It changed them in some way.
His early writings are really,
they're not good.
They're sterile and dry,
and his later writings,
the five grade novels in particular are
there in a.
they're in a class of their own.
So Dostoevsky.
The first thing Dostoevsky tried to come
to grips with was the fact he didn't
believe that life itself was a rational
because that's an enlightenment
proposition,
that the structure of reality is in and
of itself rational so it can be held.
It can be dealt with by rational means
and that's been a very powerful theory
because it's enabled us to develop.
This is scientific viewpoint and the
technology that goes along with it,
but rationality is not the only mode of
human knowing.
There's all sorts of other modes of
human knowing and many of those are
associated with emotion and motivation.
They're more biologically instantiated,
saying less computational and
rationality has a very difficult time
even conceptualizing how those other
modes of knowing might be real and so
what it tends to do is denigrate them as
mirror opponents to rationality,
but the Dostoevsky and perspective,
and this is also something that Roger's
followed up on and young,
was that life itself is so irrational or
experience itself is so irrational.
Given it suffering and its and its
absurdity.
That a merely rationally formulated
representation of life is insufficient.
It can't.
It can't manage the job and what
rationality will they're there for do is
cut away everything from life,
cutaway,
everything from its definition of
reality that it can't actually
encapsulate.
Dostoyevsky
said in short,
one may say anything about the history
of the world,
anything that might enter the most
disordered imagination.
The only thing one can't say is that
it's rational.
The very word sticks in one's throat
and indeed this is the odd thing that is
continually happening.
They're continually turning up in life,
moral and rational persons,
sages and lovers of humanity who make it
their object to live all their lives as
morally and rationally as possible,
to be so,
to speak,
a light to their neighbors simply in
order to show them that it is possible
to live morally and rationally in this
world,
and yet we all know that these very
people sooner or later have been false
to themselves.
That's a precursor of Freudian ideas
playing some queer trick often and most
unseemly one.
Now I asked you what can be expected of
band since he is a being endowed with
such strange qualities,
shower upon him,
every earthly blessing drown them in a
sea of happiness so that nothing but
bubbles of bliss can be seen on the
surface,
give them economic prosperity so that he
should have nothing else to do,
but sleep,
eat cakes and busy himself with the
continuation of the species and even
then out of sharing gratitude and spite
man would play you some nasty trick.
He would even.
Risk is cakes and would deliberately
desired the most fatal rubbish,
the most uneconomical absurdity simply
to introduce into all this positive good
sense,
his fatal fantastic element.
It is just as fantastic.
Dreams is vulgar.
Folly that he will desire to retain
simply in order to prove to himself as
if that was so necessary that men are
still men and not the keys of a piano,
which the laws of nature threatened to
control so completely that soon one will
be able to desire nothing except by the
calendar.
And that's not at all.
Even if men really were nothing but a
piano key.
Even if this were approved to him by
natural science and mathematics,
even then he would not become
reasonable.
He would do purposefully do something
perverse out of simple in gratitude
simply to gain his point,
and if he does not find means he will
contrive destruction and chaos and
suffering of all sorts,
only to gain his point.
He will launch a curse upon the world
and as only men can curse gets his
privilege.
The primary distinction between him and
other animals.
Maybe by his curse alone,
he will obtain his object.
That is to convince himself that he's a
man and not a piano key.
And if you say that all of this too can
be calculated and tabulated and chaos
and darkness and curses.
So the mere possibility of calculating
it all beforehand would stop.
It all and reason would reassert itself.
That man would purposefully go mad in
order to be rid of reason and gain his
point.
I believe in it.
I answer for it.
For the whole work of man really seems
to consist of nothing but proving to
himself every minute that he's a man,
not a piano key.
It might be at the cost of his skin,
it might be by cannibalism and this
being so can one help being tempted to
rejoice that it is not yet come off and
that desire still depends on something
we don't know.
You will scream at me.
That is if you condescend to do so that
no one is touching my freewill,
that all they're concerned with is that
my free will should have itself of its
own free will coincide with my own
normal interests and the laws of nature
and arithmetic.
Good Heavens.
Gentlemen,
what sort of free will is left when he,
when we come to tabulation and
arithmetic,
when it will all be a case of twice two,
makes four,
twice.
Two,
makes four without my will.
As a freewheel meant that
well that was written
and the late teenage,
late 18 hundreds is as well,
and Dostoevsky had already figured out
by that point that the consequence of
the new ideas swimming into Russia and
undermining Orthodox Christianity,
which was the say,
the natural culture in some sense of
Russia was going to be either nihilism
or totalitarianism,
and he examined the propositions of
totalitarianism and the propositions of
totalitarianism.
We're essentially utopian,
so the idea was except it's like a cult,
except this mode of being except this
interpretation of the world and society
will advance towards a point where while
it's saying the case of communism,
wealth is equally distributed in,
everyone is free and it's a very,
very powerful idea obviously because it
attracted hundreds of millions of people
each according
to each,
according to his need,
from each according to his ability.
Sounds Fair.
You get what you.
You get what you need to live and you
contribute what's in it,
what's in you to contribute,
and when it was laid out in the world,
it was an absolute catastrophe.
And Dostoevsky criticized this before it
even happened.
He said,
look,
human beings do not want utopia.
We're too insane for that.
If you,
if you had comfort,
sterile comfort,
if you had everything you want to just
given to you,
all you do is go crazy just so that you
wouldn't have to be bored by all that
perfection.
You destroy it so that the irrational
element that's inside of you,
so this Dionysian element could leap out
and live and so whatever utopia is,
it's not the permanent solution to all
of your problems.
You don't even want to live without
problems.
Kierkegaard writing out a little earlier
on,
but all along the similar,
a similar track of ideas.
He's also criticizing idea of utopia,
believing at least in part,
that the meaning in life is to be found
within the struggle that constitutes
life and not in the solution to that
struggle which may be as equivalent to
death and not to utopia.
It is about four years ago that I got
the notion of wanting to try my luck as
an author.
I remember it quite clearly.
It was a Sunday.
Yes,
Sunday afternoon.
I was seated as usual outside at the
cafe in the Fredericksburg Garden.
I'd been a student for half a score of
years,
although never lazy.
Oh,
my activity nevertheless was like a
glittering inactivity,
a kind of occupation for which I still
have a great partiality and for which
perhaps I even have a little genius.
I read much spent the remainder of the
day idling and thinking or thinking an
idling,
but that was all it came to,
so I sat there and I smoke my cigar
until I lapsed into thought among other
thoughts.
I remember these you are going on.
I said to myself to become an old man
without being anything and without
really undertaking to do anything on
other hand,
wherever you look around you in
literature and in life,
you see the celebrated names and
figures,
the precious and much heralded men who
are coming into prominence and are much
talked about,
the many benefactors of the age who know
how to benefit mankind by making life
easier and easier.
Somebody railways,
others by omnibuses and steamboats,
others by the telegraph,
others by easily apprehended compendiums
and short recitals of everything worth
knowing,
and finally the true benefactors of the
age who makes spiritual existence in
virtue of thought easier and easier,
yet more and more significant,
and what are you doing here?
My soliloquy was interrupted because my
cigarette with smoked out and a new one
had to be lit so I smoked again,
and then suddenly this thought flashed
into my mind,
you must do something,
but in as much as with your limited
capacities,
it will be impossible for you to make
anything easier than it has already
become.
You must with the same humanitarian
enthusiasm as the others undertake to
make something harder.
This notion pleased me immensely and at
the same time,
it flattered me to think that I liked
the rest of them would be loved in
esteemed by the whole community,
for when all combined in every way to
make everything easier,
there remains only one possible danger,
namely that the eas will become so great
that it becomes altogether too great.
Then there's only one left,
although it is not yet a felt want,
when people will want difficulty out of
love for mankind and out of despair at
my embarrassing situation,
seeing that I had accomplished nothing
and was unable to make anything easier
than it had already been made and moved
by a genuine interest in those who make
everything easy.
I can save that as my task to create
difficulties everywhere.
Character guard is often regarded as an
existentialist.
Now,
one of the ideas that runs its way
through existentialism is the idea that
to be human is to simultaneously be
saddled with an intrinsic
responsibility,
a moral responsibility that you are
responsible not only to yourself,
to your soul saying,
but also to the people around you and
that that isn't
an arbitrary imposition that's imposed
upon you by rationality or by your
fellow man for that matter,
but something that's right at the heart
of the reality of existence itself,
such that if you
fort
or fall short of bearing,
that responsibility,
you'll pay a price in guilt and in shape
and it's suffering.
Vince Wanger and brought boss working
off heidegger's lead said that guilt and
fear our debts to possibility.
If you're guilty about something,
well it's because you're not upholding
your responsibility.
Whereas for Freud that was often a form
of pathology,
excess guilt,
and of course excess guilt can become
pathological,
but Kierkegaard,
his point is that guilt itself isn't
something to be cured.
It's,
it's,
it's an integral and necessary part of
reality.
Just like disgust and despair and fear
and all the negative emotions.
They alert you to your place in the
world and guide you towards the
unfolding of your spirit.
Failure to shoulder your existential
burden is what results in neurotic,
guilt and fear,
Vince Wanger and boss also believed that
like existential anxiety and that's the
feeling of nothingness,
is fear of loss of world.
That the world that you inhabit,
the conceptual world that you inhabit
can be destroyed at any moment and that
you're aware of that at some level.
It's the same comment that needs to made
and and and Nisha believe that this was
something that modern people were
particularly susceptible to because our
rationality is always capable of sawing
off the branch that we're sitting on
because no matter what you're doing,
even if you're engaged in it deeply,
the critical part of your mind can
always say,
well,
what makes you think that's so
worthwhile?
And you know an answer could be,
well,
it manifests itself as being worthwhile
and why should I pay attention to those
rational doubts,
but that's not how we're trained.
We're trained that rationality is the
thing that encompasses everything.
Instead of being trained.
That rationality is something that's
encompassed by something else,
and so if doubts come up that
irrational,
we immediately believed them because the
rational,
instead of asking ourselves,
well,
if the rational doubt is undermining the
meaning in my life and making it
difficult for me to proceed,
maybe the thing to do is to question
whether or not that doubt is valid.
Now it depends on what you regard as
real because if it's,
if it's the rational argument itself
that's real,
then you can't dispense with the doubts,
but if you say,
well,
rationality is too limited in its
apprehension to deal with the absurdity
of life.
There are other sorts of answers like
music for example,
or or art or or the kind of engagement
that you,
that you experienced when you're
involved in something that you're
incredibly interested in.
Those are forms of reality that are that
you can regard those as forms of reality
that transcend rationalism instead of
being something embedded inside
rationalism that can be destroyed by
doubt,
and the problem with doubt is that it
can undermine you completely.
Not Smiling,
but even worse than that.
It can lay you open to ideological
possession and that's,
that's say tannic in its in its,
in its catastrophe.
We're all talked to you a little bit now
about the concentration camp
concentration camps were established
there.
There were established in England,
Germany,
Russia,
China,
Cambodia and Yugoslavia,
and in the Soviet Union,
the estimates,
these are estimates that were derived by
soldier nets and where that 66 million
people died and internal repression in
the Soviet Union between 19,
19 and 1959.
That's a figure that's 10 times as great
as the figures that are commonly used to
describe the genocide rate in the
Holocaust,
which was more like 6 million and so
it's and it's and also estimated,
but no one knows that 100 million people
died in China during Mao's cultural
revolution.
When Michael decided that he was going
to wipe out all of Chinese tradition and
destroyed much of the much of the
ancient artifacts that characterize that
tradition in a,
in a like a riotous catastrophe that
lasted more than a decade.
Oh,
Solzhenitsyn says the imagination and
strength,
spiritual strength of Shakespeare's
evildoers stopped short and it doesn't
corpses because they had no idea ology
ideology.
That's what gives evil doing.
It's long sought justification and gives
the evildoer the necessary steadfastness
and determination.
That's the social theory,
which helps to make his act seem good.
Instead of bad in his own eyes and
others,
this was how the agents of the
inquisition fortified their wills by
invoking Christianity,
the conqueror of foreign lands by
extolling the grander of their
motherland,
the colonizers by civilization that
Nazis by race and the Jacob begins early
and late by equality,
brotherhood and the happiness of future
generations without evildoers.
That would have been new archipelago.
The archipelago,
the Gulag archipelago is social
knutson's metaphor for the for the
prison camps like the prison camps that
exists now in Korea in which millions of
people are starving and dying for the.
For the prison camps that littered the
entire Soviet Union and those cultures
became so pathological that in east
Germany,
for example,
before the wall fell down and East
Germany was arguably one of the more
civilized parts of the Soviet state.
One person out of three was a government
informer.
So if you have a family of five people,
there's a reasonable probability that
two of them are going to tell a
government agent what you say and think,
and that that was also portrayed as the
highest possible moral virtue because it
was much better for you to be a
admirable citizen of the state than say
a loyal daughter,
and that's where children were taught in
school,
that the family was a defunct unit and
that individual relationships were
secondary and not all that mattered was
adherence to the dog.
With that constituted,
this central axioms of the state
is this Solzhenitsyn's description of
how communist ideological uniformity was
enforced.
In the prison camp,
an anonymous author is told how
executions were carried out at a Dac,
a camp on the river.
They would take the opposition members
with their things out of the camp
compound on a prisoner transport at
night and outside the compound stood the
small house of the third section.
The condemned men were taken into a room
one at a time and they.
The camp guards sprang on them.
Their mouths were stuffed with something
soft and their arms were bound with
cords behind their backs.
Then they were led out into the
courtyard where harnessed carts were
waiting.
The bound prisoners were piled on the
carts from five to seven at a time and
driven off to the Gorkha,
the camp cemetery.
On arrival,
they were tipped into big pits that had
already been prepared and buried alive,
not out of brutality.
No,
it had been ascertained
that weren't dragging and lifting them.
It was much easier to cope with living
people.
Corpses,
the work went on for many nights at a
DAC and that is how the moral political
unity of our party was achieved.
If you have a rigid belief system and
that's what it is because it's axioms
are such that it encompasses all of
reality and then there are details left
outside that don't seem to fit into that
reality well then you ignore that,
but what if they're embodied?
What if there are people who are
objecting to the way you think?
Well,
the equivalent to repressing evidence
that runs contrary to your theory is the
murder of people who object to what you
say,
and those two things are linked much
tighter than you would think you know,
you might think,
well,
I would never do something like the
Communists did in,
in,
in the what?
The,
the evangelization of my beliefs.
But the truth of the matter is,
is that in general,
people will do such things if they're
granted the and provided with the proper
apparatus.
This is Frankel from his accounts of the
concentration camps under Nazi Germany.
The most ghastly moment of the 24 hours
of camp life was the awakening when at a
steel nocturnal our,
the three shrill blows have a whistle,
Torres Pediculus,
Leslie from are exhausted,
sleep and from the longings in our
dreams.
We then began to tussle with our wet
shoes into which we could scarcely force
our feet,
which were sore and swollen with edema,
and then there were the usual moans and
groans about petty troubles such as the
snapping of wires which replaced
shoelaces.
One morning I heard someone whom I knew
to be brave and dignified cry like a
child because he finally had to go out
to the snowy marching fields in his bare
feet as the shoes were too shrunken for
him to wear.
In those ghastly moments,
I found a little bit of comfort,
a small piece of bread which I drew out
of my pocket and munched with absorbed
delight,
Solzhenitsyn.
Many of the Gulag camps contained two
classes of prisoners,
rapists,
murderers and thieves who were very well
organized in Russia and the Soviet Union
and political prisoners,
and because the Soviets believed that
the reason that people were thieves,
murderers and rapists was because of the
appalling sociological conditions that
they grew up into.
They believed they were socially
friendly elements who could still be
redeemed,
so they put them in charge of the camps,
and so the political prisoners were at
the bottom of the hierarchy.
The prisoners ran the camps with minimal
supervision and the counts were often
forced labor camps and forced labor
meant do something difficult and
pointless until you die.
It didn't mean it meant only secondarily
produced something of potential value to
the state.
You saw this with Nazi Germany to the
Nazis.
When they started to lose the Second
World War,
they could have stopped their holocaust
machinations and used the people they
had imprisoned
to build implements to further the war
effort,
which they did to some degree so they
could have used them as slaves.
So this would be the logic.
Take the slaves,
make the munitions when the war.
Then after you've won the war,
you can run around and mop everybody up,
but that isn't what the Nazis did when
they started to lose.
Instead of doing what you think would be
rational in the pursuit of what was
hypothetically their goal,
they amped up the killing and and took
resources away from the war itself and
some of the conclusion that's reasonable
to draw from that is that the killing
was the purpose of the war.
All the rest of it was just window
dressing and exactly as associates and
described in the earlier quotes that I
told you was ideology was only there to
allow the people who were fundamentally
motivated,
motivated towards genocide and
destruction to pretend to themselves
that they hadn't become rotten to the
absolute core,
but when push came to shove and they had
to show where their allegiances lie,
they weren't even.
They weren't even valid followers of the
Nazi party because they put the
continued pursuit of death above their
own survival even as an ideology and
that's how we the only Gigi generates.
And part of the reason for that is that
the narrower the box that you stuffed
yourself into,
the weaker your character becomes
because there's nothing left of you.
You're just a shell that has demons in
it and but you're still the sort of
thing that can suffer.
And so if you cram everything,
you are into a box,
a small box,
and you get rid of everything that
doesn't fit.
You get rid of everything in you that
makes life bearable and then life
becomes unbearable and then if life
becomes unbearable,
well then of course you're motivated to
do nothing but to take revenge on it
because why wouldn't you?
If all you were doing with suffering
stupidly and meaninglessly,
how could you positively,
how could you possibly show a positive
face to yourself into the rest of
humanity in called lower than 60 degrees
below zero work days were written off.
In other words,
on such days,
the records show that the workers had
not gone out to work.
They were often digging canals on the
frozen Siberian prairie by hand.
There was one canal,
I think it was on the river,
but I can't remember precisely,
so Stalin killed 300,000 people in a
single winter digging it by hand and
when it was done,
it was so shallow that no ships could
use it.
The record showed that the workers had
not gone out to work,
but they chased them out anyway and
whatever they squeezed out of them on
those days was added to the other days.
Thereby raising the percentages and the
survival medical section road off those
who froze to death on such cold days on
some other basis and the ones who were
left who could no longer walk and we're
straining every sinew to crawl along on
all fours on the way back to camp,
the convoy simply shot so that they
wouldn't escape before they could come
back.
The.
This is from William Blake whole rose,
the art sick.
The invisible world that flies in the
night in the howling storm have found
out diabetic crimson joy and his dark
secret.
Love does die.
Life destroy
is a soldier in Edson fire.
Fire the branches,
crackle in the night.
Wind of late autumn blows up the
flame of the bonfire,
back and forth.
The compound is dark.
I'm alone at the bonfire and I can bring
it still some more carpenter shavings.
This compound here is a privileged one,
so privileged that it's almost as if I
were out in freedom.
This is an island of paradise.
This is the Marfino Sriracha,
a scientific institute staff by
engineers
staffed with prisoners in its most
privileged period.
No one is overseeing me,
calling me to a cell,
chasing me away from the bonfire,
and even then it is chilly in the
penetrating wind,
but she was already been standing in the
wind for hours,
her arms,
straight down,
her head drooping,
weeping,
and then growing,
numb and still,
and then again,
she begs pityingly,
citizen chief,
please forgive me.
I won't do it again.
The wind carries her moan to me just as
if she were moaning next to my ear.
The citizen chief at the gate house
fires up his stove and does not answer.
This was the gatehouse of the camp next
door to us from which workers came into
our compound to lay water pipes and
repair the old ramshackle seminary
building across from me beyond the art.
Fully intertwined many stranded barb
wire barricade and two steps away from
the gate house beneath a bright lantern
stood the punished girl head hanging the
wind tugging at her gray work skirt her
feet growing numb from the cold
and a thin scarf over her head.
It had been warmed during the day when
they had been digging a ditch on our
territory.
And another girl slipping down into a
ravine had crawled your way to the Vladi
Kino highway and escaped a guard had
bungled.
And Moscow city buses ran right along
the highway.
When they caught on,
it was too late to catch her.
They raised the alarm,
a mean dark major arrived and shouted
that if they failed to catch the girl,
the entire camp would be deprived of
visits and parcels for a whole month.
Because of her escape
and the women bring it.
Tears went into a rage and they were all
shouting.
One of them in particular,
who kept a viciously rolling her eyes.
Oh,
I hope they catch her.
The bitch.
I hope they take scissors and clip,
clip,
take off all her hair in front of the
lineup.
This wasn't something she had thought of
herself.
This is the way they punished women in
the Gulag.
But the girl who was now standing
outside the gate house in the cold had
sighed and said instead,
at least she can have a good time out in
freedom for all of us.
That jailer overheard what she said and
now she was being punished.
Everyone else had been taken off to the
camp,
but she had been sent outside there to
stand at attention in front of the gate
house.
This had been at 6:00 PM and it was now
11:00 PM.
She tried to shift from one foot to
another,
but the guard struck out his head and
shoulder stand at attention,
whore or it will be worse for you and
now she was not moving.
Only weeping.
Forgive me,
citizen chief,
let me into the camp.
I won't do it anymore,
but even in the camp,
no one was about to say to her,
all right,
idiot,
come on in.
The reason they were keeping her out
there,
so lauren was that the next day was
Sunday and she would not be needed for
work.
Such a straw.
Blonde,
naive,
uneducated,
uneducated slip of a girl.
She had been in prison for some spool of
thread.
What a dangerous thought.
You expressed their little sister.
They want to teach you a lesson for the
rest of your life.
Fire,
fire.
We fought the war and we looked into the
bonfires to see what kind of victory it
would be.
The wind wafted a glowing husk from the
bonfire
to that flame in you.
Girl,
I promise the whole wide world will read
about you
from Milton.
This is from paradise.
Lost.
Milton wrote,
paradise lost just before the rise of
the nation states and melt and also had
the intuition that there was something
wrong with rationality and he identified
rationality with the mythology of Satan
and in the mythology of Satan,
Satan was
represented as the highest angel in
God's heavenly kingdom.
So you can think about that as the
highest psychological function who had
rebelled against God and that was then
cast into hell.
And the idea.
There's an idea that's being expressed
by Milton.
He was.
He was one of the most.
He was one of the foremost politik
geniuses of the English language milkmen
Shakespeare and what Milton was trying
to understand what's what is the nature
of evil and his representation gathered
up the dream like theories of evil that
had been collected around all of Western
civilization for thousands of years.
And his hypothesis was this.
Evil is the force that believes that
it's knowledge is complete and that it
can do without the transcendent and as
soon as it makes that claim,
it instantly exists in a place that's
indistinguishable from hell and it could
get out merely by admitting it's error
and it will never do that
for when,
but from the author of all ill could
spring so deep,
a malice to confound the race of mankind
in one route and earth withheld to
mingle and involve done all to spite the
great creator.
This is from Richard the Third
Shakespeare.
I shall despair.
There is no creature,
loves me,
and if I die,
no soul will pity me,
nay,
wherefore should they.
Since that I myself find in myself,
no pity to myself.
Soldier knits and describes the
reactions inactions of Communist Party
members who are devoured by the system
because that often happened.
The the,
the,
the prison system.
The [inaudible] system was very in
discriminating.
You could land there for good reasons or
bad and the bad reasons.
We're probably better because the
punishment was more severe.
If you were in prison for your innocence
and Communist Party members often got
vacuumed up and this was ontologically
and existentially intolerable for them
because they committed their whole soul
to the ideological dogma and then it's
it's tyrannical aspect.
Pick them up and destroyed them like
they were worth nothing to say that
things were painful for them is to say
almost nothing.
They were incapable of assimilating such
a blow,
such a downfall and from their own
people to form their own dear party.
The typical arrest was you're at home
with your family in your bed and it's
3:00 in the morning and the doors kicked
down and they take you out of your bed
in whatever you happen to be wearing and
they tell you to say goodbye to your
family and give you like 25 seconds to
pack and then you're gone and no one
sees you again.
They take you to the prison.
They take off all your clothes.
They shave your head.
They have you pick out some random
clothes from a pile of clothes.
Hopefully they don't fit and then you're
tried.
You confess,
if you will,
and you're off to the prison camp to say
that things were painful for them,
is to say almost nothing.
They were incapable of assimilating such
a blow,
such a downfall and from their own
people to from their own dear party and
from all appearances for nothing at all.
After all,
they had been guilty of nothing as far
as the party was concerned,
nothing at all.
It was painful to them to such a degree
that it was considered taboo among them
on comradely to ask what were you in
prison for?
They were the only squeamish generation
of prisoners.
The rest of us with our tongues hanging
out,
couldn't wait to tell the story to every
chance newcomer we met and to the whole
cell as if it were an anecdote.
Here's the sort of people they were told
us.
The Oseberg's husband had already been
arrested and they had come to carry out
a search and arrest her too.
The search lasted for hours and she
spent those four hours sorting out the
minutes of the congress of the bristle
brush industry,
of which she had been the secretary
until the previous day.
The incomplete state of the minutes
troubled her more than her children who
she was now leaving forever.
Even the interrogator conducting the
search could not resist telling her,
come on now,
say farewell to your children.
Here's the sort of people they were a
letter from her 15 year old daughter
came to yellows,
Aventa,
set Cova in the prison for longterm
prisoners.
Mama,
tell me,
write to me,
are you guilty or not?
I hope you weren't guilty because then I
won't join the Komsomol,
which was the young communist
organization and I won't forgive them
because of you,
but if you are guilty,
I won't write you anymore and I will
hate you.
And the mother was stricken by remorse
in her damp grave like cell with it's
dim little lamp.
How could her daughter lived without the
Komsomol?
How could she possibly be permitted to
hate Soviet power?
Better that she should hate me.
And so she wrote,
I am guilty.
Enter the Komsomol,
how could it be anything but hard.
It was more than the human heart could
bear to fall beneath the beloved acts
and then to have to
justify its wisdom,
but that's the price of man pays for
interesting,
his God given salty human dogma.
Even today,
any orthodox communist will affirm that
set go the acted correctly even today.
They cannot be convinced that this is
precisely quote the perversion of small
forces that the mother perverted her
daughter and harmed her soul.
Here's the sort of people they were yt
gave sincere testimony against her
husband.
Anything to aid the party.
Oh,
how one could pity them if they at least
had come to comprehend their former
wretchedness.
This whole chapter could have been
writing quite differently if today,
at least they had forsaken their earlier
views,
but it happened the way Marissa Daniel
had dreamed it would.
If I leave here someday,
I'm going to live as if nothing had
taken place.
Loyalty in our view,
it's just plain pigheadedness.
Those devotes to the theories of
development,
construed loyalty to that development to
mean renunciation to any personal
development whatsoever.
As Nikolai Adamovich villain,
chuck said,
after serving 17 years,
we believed in the party and we were not
mistaken.
Is this loyalty or pigheadedness?
No,
it was not for show and not out of
hypocrisy.
Hypocrisy that they argued in the cells
and defense of all the government's
actions.
They needed ideological arguments in
order to hold onto a sense of their own
rightness.
Otherwise insanity was not far off.
Is this from paradise lost?
So in this scene,
Satan is cast into hell and it's because
of his rebellion against the
transcendent.
His idea that he himself is sufficient.
This is his statement to his crew,
farewell,
happy fields where joy forever dwells.
Hail horrors,
hail infernal world and Dow Profundus.
Tail received.
I knew possessor,
one who brings a mind not to be changed
by place or time.
The mind is its own place and in itself
can make a heaven of hell or hell of
heaven.
What matters?
Where if I be still the same and what I
should be all but less than he whom
thunder have made greater.
Here at least we shall be free.
The Almighty hath not built here for his
envy will not drive us,
hence here we may rain,
secure and in my choice to reign is
worth ambition,
though.
Inhale better to reign in hell than
serve in heaven.
The existentialists of the late 19th
century attempted to diagnose the
pathology of the human personality at a
deeper level.
I believe that anyone else had ever
attempted,
and there are fundamental conclusion was
that
there are destruction by rationality of
the evolved systems of meaning that
people had
previously lived within,
had undermined
the psychological strength of each
individual divorced from their own
history
that led them to be to gravitate towards
either nihilism or as a counter position
to gravitate towards totalitarianism.
The whole 20th century played out the
pendulum swing between nihilism and
totalitarianism and in the background
the existentialists and the
psychodynamic theorists were putting
forward a theory which was that if
people lived up to their own possibility
and held onto their own experience as if
it were true and did not substitute for
that idiot,
logical and consensual beliefs,
that it would be possible for each
person to find a wellspring of meaning.
That would be a sufficient replacement
for what had been lost historically
without having to fall into the pitfalls
of nihilism or totalitarianism,
and so you might say,
well,
nihilism.
Well,
that's one thing because it's mostly
that effects you,
although if you're nihilistic than
everyone around you is going to be
pulled down as well,
but totalitarianism is a whole different
issue because what we know now is that
once things become ideologically
totalitarian,
the next step is mass murder and and it.
It's the next step is mass murder in a
manner that makes it appear that the
purpose for the ideological rigidity
vacation to begin with was the
opportunity to participate in mass
murder.
So you know how Hitler died.
Hitler lost faith in the German people
because they were
losing the war,
and so he concluded in the waning stages
of world war two,
that Germany should just be destroyed in
fire and everything else that he could
possibly consume would go with them.
And so he died in a bunker underneath
Berlin when it was in flames.
He committed suicide when Europe was
inflamed and Hitler was a worshiper of
the kind of fire that purifies,
use that mythology of cleansing fire to
to enter into a terrible pact with the
with the entire nation that he followed
and lead and Stallon Stellan just didn't
just kill individuals that he pulled off
the streets.
He killed like all the engineers and all
the doctors because he believed they
were records.
They killed all the good farmers.
They killed 6 million Ukrainians.
They moved whole nations of people into
Siberia and let them die and there's
every,
every bit of evidence there is suggest
that what Stalin was doing was
practicing murderous genocide on an ever
larger scale and hoping that it would
culminate in a thermonuclear war
and we escaped that just by a thread.
The existentialists make that claim,
which I think is a remarkable and
powerful claim that the way out of those
catastrophic situations is not through
political action per se or it's not
going to be resolved by one party
defeating another or one position
defeating another.
That's our continuation of the same
process that produces the problem,
the existential and the psychodynamic
answer to this problem is that it's more
a disease of the soul than a disease of
the state,
and that the way to address it is to
ensure that you live in a manner that
makes you neither nihilistic nor
susceptible to ideological possession.
Soldier in Edson
and uh,
and other other thinkers liked him,
liked frankl,
believed that this society was a
macrocosm of the individual,
not the other way around.
Not that the individual is sub element
of society believed that the choice that
each individual made was potentially so
powerful in relationship to pathological
behavior or honest or honest and
thoughtful behavior that a single
individual properly developed could
stand up against the tyranny and wind.
And it seems to me,
and I thought about this for a very long
time,
that the lesson of the 20th century is
that a single individual can stand up
against a tyrant and when,
and each of us are single individuals
and the danger of tyranny and the danger
of nihilism or not passed.
And so as inheritors of the catastrophic
legacy of the 20th century and there's
inhabitants of the new millennium,
part of your responsibility is to live
your own life and to live it honestly,
and to pay attention to your own
experience and not take the easy way out
that ideological systems offer you.
They're destined to transform themselves
into rigid and murderous pathologies.
And you offload your responsibility for
thinking and acting to them.
And then you have to ask yourself,
well,
what are they?
Well,
all the evidence suggests that they're
not the sort of thing that you want to
have in your head.
The grades are up.
We'll see you on Tuesday.